- I've been in jail all,
damn near all my life.
I aint never been a coward.
I aint never been a PC.
I aint never worked with the police.
And I aint never went on the other side
of the field and gave shit up.
I walk my walk whatever time I had to do,
I served it.
I didn't cross the line and
give the police no information,
in order for me to be a better person,
in order for me to be
able to walk that walk.
I walked it because I had time to do.
I don't share bread with the officers.
I don't do that.
I know my responsibility.
And I know my obligations.
I know my priorities.
And I know my, I know
my rules that I follow,
and I don't break 'em for nobody.
If I tell you my word is good,
that's where I stand behind.
I don't make promises that I can't keep.
But I stand behind
everything that I tell you.
I'm not a buster.
I'm not a mark.
I'm not a bitch.
I'm a soldier that stands on
the front line of this shit.
And like I said again, I
ain't afraid of nothing.
You can send your best buddy at me.
He can be King Kong son,
I'll take his ass on.
And if he whoop me,
at least I know I took him on.
That's how I stand, man, you know.
I stand in these streets now.
And I'm not afraid to walk these streets,
and you have to be strong
in order to walk because
you see so much shit goes on at night
you'd be surprised to see that
your heart is still pumping.
That's how scary some of the
shit that you have to live
with out here and keep
going and keep your mother,
keep your motherfucking mouth shut.
And just go.
Let yo day be yo day.
And don't let it be the
things that you spilled out
and told the wrong person.
Because if you do, you might
not live to see the next one.
So watch what you say.
Certain things you can't say
and there's certain things you can say.
That's the truth, dog.
I just burning up right now.